today tell you I have bosses
I warn it's not for thieves
it's a bit like truth action it makes
yake action kind of what I
think really disappointed to make
agree no  kindergarten no
if we can warm up a goal a little
contentment we
never
honestly make friends before me really but
it's a game it's a terrible drop
reached 10 to the little ears of everything
exciting good me his little buttocks no
we play well we  go have fun without a
roof without you
hard
[Music]
what are you doing there these palettes he
said to me you are having a party I am we
will have to talk more because we believe
I say something alex I do  something
that shouldn't have been
well I don't understand seriously I say
never was afraid that you want to talk about the mas
du pont and there you talk to me more thinly
it's you who invited me to spend the
night that's not it  only my request and no well
yeah but I think
you looked sad
I didn't want them to be sad
stay a day
I don't have the energy to manage
you
I don't want to eat
I produce don't stay there
[Music]